je suis sourde et mons insee isabelle il
et entendants et sans signe ses griffes
dans notre culture
chez nous les sourds on est
essentiellement visuel
ça concerne les couleurs qu'on adore
pour les objets par exemple pour les
vêtements la décoration et je réfléchis
je crois que j'ai envie de m'acheter un
vêtement d'une certaine couleur on est
transporté dans le magasin là il ya des
22 les robes accroché bleu bleu une robe
bleue quel est le prix
dessiner comme ça non c'est les
intendants nous c'est en fait très
différemment
c'est simple 10 euros voilà 10 euros pas
mal pas mal
voilà c'est pas mal rose rose le prix
pour cette robe
vous avez vu comment il fait c'est pas
comme ça c'est simple on ne fait pas ça
20 euros
ben gros voilà
félicitations on va voir blanc blanc le
prix
c'est simple quand pourquoi faire
compliqué 10 20 30
voilà euros 30 euros
un bravo encore jaune jaune le prix ça
c'est des entendants c'est toujours très
lourd alors qu'on peut faire très
simplement 40 10 20 30 40 40 euros
bravo cette robe jaune de 40 euros je
veux l'acheter je la paye et au revoir à
bientôt
je suis sourde magasin
robe couleur rose bleu blanc jaune prix
20 30 40 euros
au revoir à bientôt